yes every mm superhero has a moment
where he stares into the moonlight and
thinks about the line that he bucked up
on
and there's a bull's-eye on your
forehead I have not seen the script oh
yeah that's right yeah the script oh
yeah yeah cuz I work yeah I'm not gonna
be in this one I was gonna say we should
probably clarify that from because
masturbation yeah Malcolm was originally
gonna be out of town so we brought the
par 4 Lando is gonna be playing the
angst but then Malcolm turns out could
stay in town I was literally just not
out today so wait oh well I can't really
change the script around so if you want
to shoot behind the scenes I'd be great
and yeah so that's what I'm gonna do
great all these lovely people especially
this city and this is where there's a
scene okay the outside or her thin white
on the outside either one does he have a
bull's eye there's a character in
daredevil called bullseye oh right
beautifully by Colin Farrell was just
like the only one him a Michael Clarke
don't get are the only ones having fun
in the movie and they're just like they
know they're in the stupidest movies
they like it's just like ha ha ha oh I'm
here so so over-the-top it's all no
we're doing a character called a target
hey Mike which always hit the targets
like not just really like clearance
prices I don't know that I have like a
target shirt at home okay yeah from back
in the day yeah I get it says target on
it well the rest is gonna look like
pretty done you know like like how
everything was done in the early
two-thousands like you know the dark
gothic movie right I was telling Jim
that I saw this movie but I don't it
wasn't
memorable I don't you know the fight
when I first saw it I remember being
stupid I repeat remembered being pretty
forgettable - well we got around to
reviewing and I'm like I forgot how much
gold is in this like there I think
because of the time period it came out
and we're making fun that time period as
well cuz you think like what ten years
ago can't be fast take a difference Doug
don't move sorry yeah you think it can't
be that big a difference but no there's
a lot of things back there it's like oh
yeah like every movie just kind of did
this for a while yeah no sorry
interesting I love all the music
everybody sings like they have like a
big wad of tobacco to it to bag on their
mouths are awesome here wait oh they
wait they were sick they were singing
the song yeah yeah I did just to me like
the songs that they play in the movie Oh
soundtrack and yeah you know even the
women okay I mean like everybody sounds
like yeah like all the songs sound that
way we will your business ah like 2003 I
think
oh yeah early 2000 yeah so there's just
this just a style to the early 2000 fit
but especially superhero films where
it's just like there's this very precise
before yellow where everyone's just
super angsty it just wasn't mean that
wasn't me goodness which is like wrist a
little bit and super-ego films but it's
like they kind of got a sense of fun
again like with the Marvel films and
stuff right yeah our night lots of
laughs I said morrow yeah marble oh no
that's it everyone was trying to be
Batman you know I think it's cuz like
there was no big kind of book explosion
and like because of stuff like Batman
and Robin and stuff like they're trying
to show know that Cowboys can be really
serious really dark and really so like
every film looked like that yeah so but
yeah the when Marvel came around like
hey can we you know have fun again right
can we like say hey yeah okay there's a
weird thing back there what's that weird
thing yeah it's like a cinavia I could
give you a context of oh I'm just gonna
say that is gonna be the Virgin Mary
puppet oh okay if you add that as you
were a virgin mary puppy I am NOT the
Virgin Mary
oh well I see yeah
all right you got the blue sure you're
dyeing your hair blue can bail so yeah
you know it's come on let's go
okay no there's a scene in the movie I
can't just had to be artistic you know I
am suffering artiste where it's like
it's flying around the city and it stops
on the stained-glass window of the
Virgin Mary and it just holds for like
five seconds until it cuts the deck see
that's like what that is no I I just
stretch it out even longer like oh yeah
tractor wants to hold me for a bit so um
it's the Virgin Mary so just gets out
but you know it's just gonna be horribly
sacrilegious like Oh spoke the liquor
dealer but no more than Daredevils yeah
and you're doing this during Lent yeah
this is perfect and during the premiere
I guess daredevil a lot which I didn't
know this has a Netflix show coming out
oh yeah that's right yeah I get it's
like you know which is like hitting a
million boys yeah
haven't you ever watch The Addams Family
or the monster oh yes very McCobb
cabaret yeah I'm out of things to say so
I'm going to look at this puppet this is
Orlando Bloom Hey oh this yeah this is
behind the scenes man really yeah
everyone's doing it okay hi hello great
hello so I gotta go back to the back
yeah Badgers on the door because I was
shaving it
I stayed there for the longest time that
one call not to go back ha I'm Ilana
please you may remember me from Melek I
yes hi my name is Orlando Belial you
might home
I believe I'm sorry my dad is for Billy
yes there you go there you go so see we
I was 37% right so yes after two years I
am back peoples hahaha did you miss me
oh I like I'm here Jim okay well I'm
just getting finish it cuz you know I
gotta watch my finger mmm let me just
yeah that according to lay and here oh
yeah yeah he's like oh people you all
gonna talk about me and two years of not
being on camera new DNA oh oh you look
fine honey earth even stuff oh it's all
make him working wonders just completely
Photoshop and CGI me yeah it's amazing
well he didn't do him ah March first was
four years is four years just awesome um
so she's got that she also has a fabric
store um yeah she just opened it up on
was it Holly same place in that mall no
no actually in downtown Kenosha she has
it opened up she opened it up on
Halloween so word is still getting out
there but people if if you're in the
Kenosha area please stop on by small
crafty finds crafty with the K check it
out now there's a Facebook page as well
and if you're in the area please go
ahead and take a look my wife would be
very delighted to force oh come on what
what store uh depends depends on the ow
I mean it really just depends on who's
there there's a few people from here and
there that come by to watch over um how
close is that to Milwaukee
I'd say about well Kenosha maybe about
45 minutes give or take oh I mean it's
right I mean you're right in between
Kenosha is right in between Chicago and
Milwaukee it's like the middle ground
right then and there I ocean Racine
oh okay I don't know what character
myself in there I'm just gonna call
myself the aim the aim the amen amen
here okay so we we're looking at this
outfit I said there has to be like
something else around like you know kind
of the you know something like a
six-pack or something cuz just like a
little too plain and big yeah this what
we're trying yeah we would I woke up in
the middle I woke up one day you know
what a huge one no you just I try to
tuck it in you where you just touch it
in the other way it's very dark helmet
tie
oh yeah just look like a tie actually no
least all right so yeah we're not doing
that find the ice spoon nice so startled
but I remain it's all right you know one
more add on this one just just with her
I am the angst and also do the boom that
used all other reaction alright just
well the choice are you ready and action
thanks to the nose oh we're all right
there
oh no yeah I thought it was like a disk
great joy thank you for giving its up
that much crap
what you know what I think like when I
do the you know what I'm gonna do the
hatch reveal laughs the more I think
about is that way Mentos spear yeah yeah
let's say that was a sort not Free
People best ways to do it yeah oh yeah
and he said you're teaching her yeah
he's a sigh why did you tell me I
could've brought miles from home I'm
only the real ones Dalton older duck
Electra's devastated hi I'm trained
right she's a trained ninja we're
trained actor just trying to get you
rain very hard at the side one two three
four five ten one two three four five
ten yes no I'm trying I'm trying to get
you in we go we have you trained with
like weapons like combat fencing
okay to use a fencing before in the
racial I took off stage stage combat
when I didn't know the fencing oh that's
pretty cool
yeah like the bring you I've got to do
like a fight see yeah we could do
something with justify no just like you
know they're like you know just an
all-consuming shadow
the choreographed fight say that'd be an
awesome yes I would love that yeah be a
fine we get vital Jackson to bring the
popcorn yeah yeah
earlier Michael Jackson in there you
know that's become a thing yeah okay
cool
also looks it okay okay I love that has
been become a thing I know like I'm just
here to read the comments I know well
duh
yeah that's the that's the whole thing
it's like well enough of an opinion
let's just see the common right
it steal some pictures exactly it's okay
so uh Lando get more in the middle here
touch me Claire we're talking about yeah
like hold on your keep on then we were
talking about because that's position
starts in and then like me yeah like
this it's like you're not short enough
damn it well what if she just can't like
slosh down and then just like appeared
and if we're gonna do that it should be
like just behind you I fancy even fire
cuz like I think it can work on why
Orlando to be Torv we can put him on
them no no it is not they could do in
contact over her her great and II was
following I think that works okay oh no
cuz the original idea was to have him
have to keep out and then like when he
brings it in she started me there for
that shot I could just go like this uh I
love you see a holdout hole at the Cape
Lando go ahead and look at him I could
see ya oh yeah I think I don't come from
behind will still be pretty funny so
this is a kill like Wednesday yeah
Wednesday garage yeah um so I'm coming
in from Spyder
yes
the last bit of long while you see this
toy object what up my butt
oh right it's a gateway in a black dick
on my chest are you guys doing filming
what kind of filming toys dick all
cozied up doll edging metal huh we're
gonna put it on YouTube
I don't think he's gonna make it make it
for a few mez and I get taken back views
right Rudy drew should have like a
brooding voice hello yes
no that's Dubois again we don't
need a reason we just need to prove yeah
that's pretty much how she sounds
okay you get the broom I can throw
together now you can hand the door okay
that's a stupid party
I never work underwear didn't wire oh no
that's right because you didn't say yeah
there's a scene where like dude I was
like you know I didn't kill your father
she's just like yeah ng spy is just the
worst delivery of one word huh sounds
like that's the take they went with yeah
hey just even tasted ink oh that's on
fire hey go ahead look at the camera for
a second uh
oh yeah small-town girl yeah what about
that one
okay um you guys uh you got down oh yes
early every roller mm so good yes but uh
usually have a super grocery chance I'm
going to think about these scary kid
because you'd be up a bad guy house the
biggest question himself and then dama
comes out we don't need a reason
we just need to see the proposed thing
she doesn't yeah I think when you come
out to just we don't need a reason
we just need to boobie should I still
have to pose no I think just hold it
you're you're too caught up in your own
and brooding every early 2000 super
handsome moment has to have a moment or
or has a moment that's probably easier
everything else in superhero has a
moment where he stares off into the
distance to think yeah that's good no
sire deadly to him
okay ready ready ready oh quit sad ready
and action
brewing brewing yes every 2002 per hero
has a moment Reese tears into the
distance to think yeah but other
superheroes usually have something to
think about he scared a kid because he
is beating up a bad guy how does that
make him question himself we don't need
a reason
we just need to brood like a like that
yeah you can even come out a little bit
for it okay uh but that was gonna take
about one more time Cameron oh just so I
can yeah that looks okay okay alright oh
it's every early mm yeah what I say I
ready 10,000 which I mean that works too
but we can work in early okay okay guys
ready
and actually Ruby brooding yes every
early 2000 superhero has a moment where
he has to stare into the distance to
think the other superheroes usually have
something to think about
he's scared a little kid because he was
beating up a bad guy how does it making
question himself we don't need a reason
we just need to brood good uh table
we'll just do your line one more time
just make a little louder just in case I
think we get it but just to be safe
alright so arms up lined up is just
going to be your life I did it again
uh as soon as I say action you'll just
do your whining ok dinner cool hey ready
and action
we don't need a reason we just need to
brew good
uh no it's just some marking gonna look
again good alright so I go who are you
and you say I am and like you can pretty
much do whatever you want with the size
I'm just getting like an open you know
like length if anything the less it
looks like it would make that sound
effect and Terra those are good do a few
more in fear that they're little - yeah
it's like yes pom-pom girl hey I said
yeah do like I like the bow being lady
did all those are really good I say you
can even do it for a bit longer and who
are you I am a ste my god where did you
learn all day my father didn't want me
to be a victim I'm amazed um you do know
women learn martial arts all the time
right
impossible there must be some strange
reason why clearly there must be some
strange reason it's low and now what
we'll just take it from that line
I'll do the leading uh you do know women
learn martial arts all the time right
impossible clearly there must be some
strange reason why very good for you um
on this one a demo with yours of me
Dibble freedom one two one two my god
that's the fire wave I see start with um
you know
phoom phoom phoom phoom phoom phoom n
whatever you want after that so I get
like phoom phoom you know like that yeah
that's good you know yeah boom boom boom
boom and then whatever you wanted to
more and f you speed it up that's what
we're probably going to do after this
one okay yeah yeah okay you already and
who are you Agustin my ex tonight it's a
catholic saint
this means nothing anymore
I cast and recreated those bundles the
actions were beautiful areas just
outside the line a ste name eggs eggs
eggs yes
who are you I am
xD my god where did you love her okay my
father didn't want me to be a victim I'm
amazed uh you do know women learn
martial arts all the time right
impossible clearly there must be some
strange reason why really good ah I'm
just gonna do a on close-up of you
saying XD let's go get back where you
were
x-gene my god where did you learn karate
XG my god where did you learn karate
God what did you learn those moves my
father didn't want me to be a victim I'm
amazed uh you know women learning
martial arts the women learn martial
arts all the time right that's a good
one yeah in between taking flowers or
not being I don't know we'd cut that
line color what do you
that was just like a agent schmuck kind
of yeah except this one actually bleeds
oh goodness this is a morbid Oh target
got you too huh they're expensive
actually yeah well sometimes they have
good sales but like their regular prices
are just horrendous strict and strong
it's strike strip a man hey Doug good
target I saw the piece we going well a
mother
amen two lanes me thanks man this is
Sonny's like chips chips delicioso
like prime potatoes fight crime and
hunger no well it'll be so neat to see
its effect with actual blood this time
because the the the one with a church
mark looks so cool like just ads I want
just the right just go in the middle
ah and then the yeah this one will get
actual blood and Joel that's you know I
really should give these to the kids in
Ethiopia I want oh well what's another
chip down the gullet the green screen
room try not to have one though
necessarily drip like matrix or like a
splat okay see my leg it's larger than
it is a little bit yeah like maybe just
a few dots of it you know why the idea
what does that have to do with the Queen
it'll just be tougher to clean up on top
of a picture to make it on the outfit
and stuff like that - so Bob topping I
want somebody she's not green blood no
no no he's a mess yes all the time
though when you shoot
despite of bloom like that now now you
can uproot and it's all dripping down my
cute guys and give you a very quick shot
so it's a shoe I love this bottle of
spirit bottle of love or printed this
song special looks realistic flows like
real blood
2007 a good year you know here's a
question if you were going to have this
blood but other language you could put
on here in this day and age French
French well I'm glad they must make
their selling it up in Canada maybe yeah
well if you're if you're in Quebec Jim
this is America by American black piece
speaking American and McDonald's
so this blood is gonna have a lot of
quests trawl in it can you handle it
Chris blood as I oh I get it
I get you there's somebody I convention
dressed up I forget her name that's so
mad means she's really nice online there
you go yeah oh that's really good wow
she got it down yeah you saw them like
off center table that's awesome what was
the Sweden atom offering in the name of
it now uh tell me come in Alabama oh wow
progressive but this news right that's
sarcasm folks Alabama fans yeah she's
gonna be like you I'm just gonna dress
up the same stuff have a big red X
across it across the other exits so how
I'm gonna get her back
all right so now uh it happens better
when what's a merkin before I call her
Rachel Rachel this is um right sure
Rachel Ray Brown Ramirez Tamara haechul
Rachel I started a YouTube channel that
has two really funny videos on it you
should check it out but it's called
ramrod cheats are games together so dumb
why cheat cheats and chamber oco-2 I
have to see it spelled yeah right for
sure
okay uh so he's in the same spot go to
Target where you were before so yeah I
think you're a little more in front of
it yeah there you go so it's going to be
so pretty much as soon as I say actually
just sort of dari head back a little bit
just head like heavier I so so sterling
and I think I have your mouth full
whatever keys you have just habit just
sort of have your eyes or go up like
here says sort of a key through this
face yeah like that so sort of two
people listen and I think you're a
little bit there you go hey ready and
action
oh sure I feel like maybe she was a
little closer oh go ahead try get a
little closer than chess uh up a bit go
that looks about right all right ready
and actually you know I you know if I
you can actually start with the face
just have a like exertion okay you know
you can play back that seen Doug
positioner I wasn't
yeah my big idea here I go go whole dead
spot - okay
record real and up and action
no board and agony while he bucks for
the camera
oh is it great it's like mr. six meets
MC Hammer's Irish leprechaun Oh in the
background and then you're like Stella
could be even more like was are you
using the frame no no you were fine okay
Oh get my breath back your reception
okay and action
though born for the more nice mournful
for Augustine this Augustine x2 here the
gloves come off oh right
still recording yep really know and
action
no morning agony while she a little bit
backward Streisand just one it's just
one in it rolling well and oh yeah
and action no morning agony while he
mugs for the camera
turned a little Richard there for a
second yeah golly Miss Molly
oh damn baby yeah Dean maybe she did no
more than angry while he mugs for the
camera
ah
okay cookie crisps kooky grins what I
don't know right okay it's insane that
worthy oh the walk you get the one
little strut you do hot - is that like
an app for your mind's eye
okay I can't do a marathon of vines I
did that once before and I've watched a
marathon of vines for an hour that
lowered my IQ Oh Eddie and action
yeah I'll soul finding good better
capita what about the current situation
oh don't worry I know just thing to stop
early 2000 heroes and villains really
what's that
look to your left now oh bloody hell the
damn song take my jacket
let's take a frontal tear left look to
your left now oh bloody hell the damn
Sun came up we can't fight during the
day we love the cooler night I'll see
you in the sequel don't never happen oh
you're dead that wouldn't make any sense
I'm talking hey that's good
now what did you want Orlando to do
while you - disappears and I don't know
if Tamara was flogged enough on her line
I'm getting ok yeah you can always trim
you I'll do okay can you understand what
I'm saying okay yes okay yes I do one
more star only right ready and action
are you all fine and good but what about
our current situation Buttercup oh I
don't know I know just the thing to stop
early too
heroes and villains really what's that
look to your left now oh bloody hell the
damn Sun came up we can't fight during
the day we little to die well I'll see
you the sequel they'll never happen I'm
getting a sequel ah your dad doesn't
make any sense
oh good good okay yeah this I love well
I like to do one more from the Sun came
up I think I can do the jingle there all
right so some we're looking at the Sun
all right still recording yeah and
action
oh well the bloody Sun came up we can't
fight during the day we looked all night
well I'll see you in the sequel they'll
never happen sequel ah your dad that
wouldn't make any sense
I'm target haha oh good point Michael
Jackson there for a second ah doing Oh
Ritchie and Michael Jackson oh uh I'll
give you the lead in lines you ready
okay so what now
well isn't it obvious I jumped through
the city looking awesome well early 2000
song plays don't make me the ones that
always sound like a southern pink is
singing with a golf ball in his mouth
very one I'll see you whenever justices
needed critic I will have no fond
memories of you angst until
you